the Joe Rogan experience what's next
like where where where you out right now
I think our our initial challenge or the
the initial goal that we're seeking to
meet here is to get I've not qualified
yet for the next debate in December what
you have to do to qualify we need to do
two things one is we've got uh surpass
two hundred thousand individual donors
that's hilarious you need money where
are you out right now we are at I think
at about a hundred ninety nine thousand
Joe Rogan's don't jump on that leg of
grenade and then the second thing is is
I think require a certain number of
polls and I think I need one more poll
to meet that requirement which is again
is directly like you look at look at a
guy like I think Pete Buddha Jed she
spent nine million dollars on social
media ads in order to get like a four
percent bump in the polls you look at
what some of these other guys have spent
some of the billionaire's I think Stiers
spent thirty seven million dollars in
order to qualify in the polls on the
debate and so our challenge is we just
need to we need to get out and get in
front of people in order to make sure
that that we're bypassing the corporate
media and we're actually talking
directly to folks at home is there a
real possibility that sometime in our
lifetime they can take money out of
politics like that yes there has to be
there has to be the more people learn
about how completely lopsided our
campaign finance system is that does two
things it favors those or it helps those
who are taking money from corporations
and PACs and lobbyists further deepening
the divide between the politicians and
the people that they are supposed to be
serving and representing and instead you
know you've got this this insider
culture of lobbyists and politicians who
are just hanging out and making the
decisions and yeah I mean look this is
the second thing is that that you're
seeing how how corrupting that influence
has is on the Elna but the polity
and influence that they have over people
and how much it's disproportionately
helping the strength and the power of a
two-party system where those parties can
can literally take like for me if if you
wanted to give me a contribution you
could give me the limit is $2,800 per
the primary twenty Harlow's but that's
it you can't no matter how much you want
you can't give me any more money
but if you wanted to write a check to
either the Democratic Party the
Republican Party doesn't matter
unlimited amount of money that you can
give to the party so what does that
actually mean it means the pout the
party has a hell of a lot of power that
they can leverage over individual
members of Congress elected leaders to
say if you don't play ball if you don't
vote the way we want you to vote we're
not going to be there to help you out in
your election we're not going to run TV
ads for you we're not going to help you
out when you're getting attacked by the
other guy which just makes the problem
that we already have worse where instead
of leaders voting based on what they
believe is right for their constituents
or right for their the the country or
based on their conscience instead
they're being goaded into voting for the
interests of the political party putting
party ahead of the interests of the
country and so that that's I think the
more people are learning about the
consequence of our existing campaign
finance system the more they're
demanding change and reform so that we
are electing leaders who are accountable
only to the people have you ever had a
conversation with someone where they
have tried to influence your vote in one
way or another in that way that you just
described I have so so you know I have
met with and you know lobbyists will say
hey here's why I want you to vote this
way and you know you know by the way
well we'll be there at your next
fundraising dinner something like that
I have vampires right there and years
ago when I stopped taking PAC money I
got no calls from any lobbyists none
when I said no PAC money no lobbyists
money automatically they're like well
obviously we can't talk to her for not
giving her much crazy
ladies not playing yeah exactly and then
I I haven't seen it you know I I
established very quickly in Congress
that that I don't play political games
and that I'm not going to be bullied
into takin anybody else's position if I
don't think it's the right one to take
so I have not experienced that kind of
like the the the the party has never
helped me in any of my elections ever
for City Council for state legislature
for Congress so them coming in and
saying well we're not gonna be like dude
you were never there for me ever anyway
but I've seen it happen with some of my
friends who maybe represent swing
districts or who are Democrats you got
elected in a Republican district they're
always gonna have a really tough race I
have seen it happen in real time where
that those bully tactics come into play
[Applause]